good afternoon I'm Ching Li from South
Korea I am a research scientist at a
tree I'm also a professor at the UST I'd
like to introduce my pixels tag function
and its applications including my first
exhibition ok I'd like to start with how
pixels tag has begun so for me it was my
first attendance to this nice conference
it was a long way from Dejan to
champagne it to almost 21.5 hours just
little yeah and the join is located in
the middle of South Korea the distance
between Seoul and Daejeon is almost
similar to Seoul and Pyongyang of North
Korea so this is a map of Korea I'm a
member sahs map of Dagon
with my photos and pixels tag came to
life between the photos taken in a
Beretta and my yoga class in my
Institute so this is my photos taken at
a Breton is my routine hobby to walk
around a Breton and taking pictures
almost every weekend and these other
samples of my pictures and this is one
of my routine hobby I'm practicing yoga
and every lunch eat time is almost 12
years for me and when I'm posing this
upside down and maybe on hand standing
position my blows are coming down it was
a two years ago I was imagining the
pictures taken the other days these
pictures I imagined data some heavy dark
pixels are coming down to the ground and
a light pieces are coming up so after
lunch I jumped into my Mathematica
notebook
and after a quick coating I could
generate this abstract images so how do
you like it I enjoyed it a very lot so
yeah the idea was very abstract but I
could not imagine the details but I
could see the details so I saw there
what happened what will happen when I
change the the position where the heavy
pixels gathers like the centre lines
like here or centre position like this
one so this one looks like a abstract
flower generated using the pixels of
real flowers is interesting and when I
move the centers to the four corners I
could get these images and very tranquil
calm gradations also so all these six
pictures are generated using the same
pixels it's lightly
I could make an analogy there if you get
a box of Lego blocks you can build many
things together so sometimes you can
build a spaceship or house or a car it's
I think it's very similar to the pixels
so I tested with many images with
different parameters so I could generate
this very big different images but they
are sharing all the same pixels so in
yoga I try to make a image using the
pixels of the other one so it's called a
pixel swap I used two pixels take
operations I'll give you more details
and this so I like to give some more
details on pixel stacks so basically
traditional existing images Imaging's
are related to finding proper color
values to the
positions right like a CMOS or rendering
grid but for pixels to operations we are
interested in finding proper positions
for fixed set of colors for example for
this given pixel grid and a color space
we can assign different colors to the
grid like this one for the same grades
depending on which pixels we choose they
have different images right but for me I
was interested in fixing the set of
pixels for the Cubans terrible Legolas I
want you to build many things sir for
these images it can be changed into
these images they are very different but
they are using the same pixels so in the
left side they other given pixels over
here but these images are quite
different but they have the same pixels
so in this slide this one is more
interesting this is a random LGB images
and they are generated using pixels tag
operations only they are quite different
I felt that I it's like a finding kind
of gemstones from the sand boxes yes
these are the basic ideas pixels tests
so I'd like to show some more examples
the first application is making abstract
images so this is a Lantana flower taken
by myself at there a Beretta it is very
different diverse colors when I apply
pixel stay operations very different
images are coming this one is my
favorite I'm I was quite a surprise to
find this kind of emergent
if you see after the session you can see
my lattice the colors are much much
better so this was and for this images I
applied the pixels text to locally to
their local patches like this one and
when I do random sampling is much
interesting so for this images I made
her a long strand of pixels and applied
a kind of a space-filling curves like a
spiral and a piano curve and Hilbert
curve they are all using the same pixels
for this images the method is similar
space-filling but before applying the
space-filling I applied a global sorting
of colors so similar Carlos are
clustered it's a piano curb and Hilbert
curve so all these sixteen images are
using the same pixels from one flower
quite interesting so second application
is I think they're the pixels take is
kind of a new way of appreciating the
master paintings so these two images
were generated to using a very famous
paintings so you know what which one is
the source you can guess can you guess
it was from this imaging go his armor
and blossom it was quite surprising that
it uses very little colors right and
these two images are from the same image
I'll go his green will fill
and this image is from co-host iris this
one served by applying pixels texture we
can enjoy colors over original paintings
and when I choose these pictures many
friends easily could find the answer the
answer is these pictures is a random
sampling of this image and this is
applying pixels take locally over the
grid on this image my third application
is applying to pixel steps to generate
one image using the pixels of the other
ones I call this pixel swapping it's a
pixel swap function so I tested with the
two images firstly one is from Claude
Monet's Japanese bridge and the second
one is acclaimed kiss so can you imagine
the result this one I could generate
very golden pond with their bridge and
green kiss
initially it was generated using the
images in the in the center the pixels
are coming from this one and these
pixels came from this one but when we
directly apply a pixel swapping the
brightness is a bit too much or too real
so in the case I hope I can apply in
test his weapon so after pixel swapping
the colors are coming from this imagery
and color brightness is coming from the
sources so we can make more enjoyable
images similar to other sources
so this Easter pictures this is the
energy generated to using the social
image of this man and pictures taken by
myself at my local a Breton with a small
pond and bridge so to photo and a
painting has swapped their colors and I
experimented with this
Kohi self-portraits with many pictures
and I found that these self-portraits
quite genius because it is using so
little colors and the genius patterns
are kind of like a kind of color sponge
it observes every colors and make itself
more different as in these examples so I
applied the pink colors of flowers taken
in the bread too
this is the animation of making these
images so it's a pixel wise transition
so in intermediate steps are quite
smooth and natural even in the large
scaling it looks quite natural as you
can see there red eyes because I'm not
considering any semantic segmentations
or things like that I'm not using neural
nets yes so it will be kind of an
accident stabbed I'm just using
algorithmic operations so I my wife and
I enjoy this images so much so we made
our print over the backs and I I'm
carrying that so in my seat that you
can't see my mister
I forgot to bring that to the pot you
I'm sorry yeah
I forgot to bring this one you can see
me please this example shows a
continuous changing of colors using
multiple flowers so starting from the
pink flowers is changing so loosely to
yellow was I'm mixed thing changing the
blend of two images continuously and
pixels were can be applied to multiple
images other than two in this case
diagonals are original paintings of
co-host and off diagonal star pixel swap
ruins in this case 15 diagonals are
famous paintings and off diagonals are
pixel swap twins when maker random
sampling it is quite interesting to find
the original ones so I wanted to give
light to this dark dining table of go
who is potato eaters and I saw their
lights could come from this
klimt kiss as here we could see many
details and we could see the the solid
family food after their hard work so I
think Danny pixel swapping is a very
interesting new way of appreciating
paintings so in this case I wanted to
mix very sacred picture an earthly one
this red one is her gambling card in the
career in Japan so I could generate this
red kiss okay in this example I want you
to make a time transition between day
and night this one is from say Johnson
and this one is from coke this is an
animation over here you can see the very
very smooth transition between day and
night and night and day
okay sir I want you to make a physical
medium of my digital painting so I
tested a postcard only this year and I
have one and after decision I can show
you and every picture has a one line of
a mass Medicare code since it was
generated actually using that function
pixel swab and P sales tax like this
ring this is a Genesis epistle stack I
love this one and my last application is
exhibition I was very lucky to be
invited in as an artist in the Science
Festival I hold two exhibitions at once
first awareness opening now IBS is a
very famous Institute of a basic science
it has her Lantana pixels test over here
and every other pictures wholly
generated using math America I'd like to
explain this but I don't have much time
so I will skip the second exhibition yes
it has a the genesis of pixel second
pinky goose and this 15 famous portraits
and others all all of them are generated
using Mathematica and it has a one line
of code
another paintings so for me they asked
them why are you doing this except
you're researching work so I answer with
this slide as you all up can you read
this one right in Korean it's very
famous Korean line and Korean line from
the Korean drama called mr. sunshine it
gets 8.8 in IMDB I was surprised to find
that he says that I love and propose
these things by nature like a moon star
flower
Winn laughter jerk it was quite
interesting that mask Mathematica was
very productive to do on on proposed
things I'd like to think thank people
behind this technology and the community
okay thank you for listening
[Applause]